The turmeric root is one of nature's marbles.
It's been used for thousands of years in Ayurvedic medicine to help maintain normal
inflammatory balance, cool the GI tract, and calm the immune system.
As research on turmeric progressed, scientists focused only on harnessing the benefits of one
active compound, curcumin, but it was quickly discovered that curcumin isn't well absorbed
by the human gut.
In order to increase absorption, special technology was developed to help curcumin slip right
through the gut wall and into the bloodstream.
But this was never shown to improve clinical efficacy.
Quickly, it became apparent that more absorption didn't equal better results.
But why?
As scientists investigated this problem, they found turmeric root has other beneficial compounds
that enhance the function of curcumin, while having benefits of their own.
It's not just about one turmeric compound, but the complete turmeric matrix.
It turns out, when this unique group of turmeric compounds is ingested, the gut microbiome
processes them and makes them bioactive to have the most impact in the body.
The bioactive turmeric can then neutralize toxins, build microbial diversity, keep inflammatory
balance in check, and support the immune system.
Turmeric was never intended to bypass the gut.
That is where it works best.
So when choosing a turmeric product, choose one with more than just one compound.
Choose one that gives you the complete turmeric matrix for full spectrum health benefits.
Tareva, made with the complete turmeric matrix, has nature intended.